[Music]
more developments tonight on how parents
and common sense americans are pushing
back against the destructive far-left
critical race theory ideology that's
infiltrating america's schools
just listen to how one virginia mom who
actually survived
now china eviscerates her local school
board
amid the district's critical race theory
push take a look at this
i've been very alarmed by what's going
on in our school you are now teaching
training our children to be social
justice warriors and to lose our country
and our history uh growing up in mouse
china all this
seemed very familiar the communist
regime used the same
critical theory to divide people the
only difference is they use class
instead of race
this is indeed the american version of
the chinese communist
the chinese cultural revolution the
critical race theory has its roots in
cultural marxism
it should have no place in our schools
and down in the great state of florida
governor ron desantis continues to be a
beacon of hope against his far left
lunacy
as the florida board of education has
approved the governor's rule
banning teaching of critical race theory
in the state's public schools
joining us now for reaction fox news
contributor jason chavitz along with the
mother you just saw
in that video she van fleet is with us
you were six years old when the cultural
revolution began in china
and you have spoken eloquently
about what it was like in school and
posters hung in hallways and teachers
and students
would would attack each other for being
ideologically and poor
and pure can you explain what you
experienced
and the similarities you see
okay um i just want to uh let the
american people know
that what's going on in our school and
in our country is
really a replay of the cultural
revolution
um in china and i i want people to see
those similarities and the similarities
are terrifying
they use the same ideology and same
methodology
even the same vocabulary and with the
same goal
the ideology is cultural marxism
and we were divided into groups as
oppressor and oppressed and here we use
rays
and there they use class and uh um
the um the people here who have a
different review
were labeled racist but in the cultural
revolution
the label is counter revolutionary so it
is a hat
that fits all and once the hat is on
your head
your life is ruined and the
the uh methodology is also
very similar it's cancelled culture we
basically cancel the whole
chinese civilization pre-communism
and we changed our school names street
names
store names we changed even our personal
names
my name is xi and i was named after the
city i was born
xi'an she means west it also refers to
the imperialism
so i want it so bad to change my name
because i want to be more
communist i'm glad my parents convinced
me
not to and the is even this
uh the same workness and uh
to be specific we used class
workness in chinese it's uh it is
gigi your level of uh
um workness determine uh your chance to
get the promotion
or to get benefit and who decides your
level of
workness and is the party leaders
yeah yeah and and you speak and you
speak from real experience i mean you
were six years old but you lived 20
years under this oppression
and it sounds like out of the lessons
you learned
under mao and the revolution you see
this group
think now appearing in america and
you're trying to warn americans that you
don't want to go down this road
um congressman chaffetz let me ask you
i mean you see what what is being taught
here what is your reaction and
do you see the similarities
uh i do see the similarities but to hear
it firsthand from z
i'm just proud of her for speaking up
i'm proud of her for
doing it the american way and actually
going out of her comfort zone
and making an issue of this so on behalf
of millions of people all across this
country
thank you for doing that uh i'm very
proud of what ron desantis is doing you
know he was on our oversight committee
he was pretty good but you know what as
governor the guy is
great and um he's doing the right thing
but it's going to take ordinary people
doing extraordinary things and so i just
want to thank her for
voicing what so many millions of people
and parents know
is happening and we got to change it
i'll give you the last word
siobhan fleet because i think what would
your message be to america if they
continue to go down this road
i just want people to know that the
freedom is fragile
and we can lose it anytime if we don't
defend it
and there's a lot of chinese americans
who have
the same experience and share my point
of view
and i know that more and more people
will stay step up
and share their stories and tell the
american people
critic critical risk theory is not
anti-racism
it is self is racist it's divisive it's
destructive
and it is dangerous all right thank you
so much i'm sorry i had to live that way
and congressman it's great to see you as
always hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else